raven simone miranda mayday it is so
nice to see the two of you i can't help
but notice
these gorgeous coordinated looks that
are going on here
what inspired this we are filming a
little video
for our channel and our new youtube
channel and um
basically christmas in may felt
appropriate giving us
holiday realness in may i'm absolutely
here for it
and you just teased that it's actually
going to be for a new video that you're
putting out on your recently launched
youtube channel congratulations i
absolutely loved the video
um about the common assumptions about
the two of you as a couple
you will have kids soon the assumption
is yes
we will have kids soon raven you
confirmed it can you
share what soon means soon means
a a couple of extra commas in the bank
saved
a youtube channel that's thriving and we
move
and then the child can come the great
thing about being this couple is that
there are no surprises
but expect a nice video on it i think
that's something we should film babes i
think we should like definitely film our
journey of
what we choose because we have many
conversations about it we're not getting
any younger
and we know that this world is you know
full of promises but never a
follow-through
and i think it's interesting too because
a lot of people
don't understand how a lesbian couple
would have a baby and
you know other than adoption so i think
sharing
the whole journey like you just said and
whatever that may look like
you know there's there are multiple
options i just have to tell you i tuned
into your instagram
uh your igtv when you guys were in the
car maybe a couple weeks back
and you touched on it a little bit we do
need to get our eggs saved soon babes
yes we need to have that conversation
for real about like getting our eggs
saved so that when it's time to have a
baby we can have a baby
i love it i'm a is so wonderful so much
money um
anyway it's so much fun can you guys
share if that is part of your journey
it hasn't been yet we haven't started
that process but i think
it probably will be as raven said we're
not getting any younger
and you know freezing your eggs so you
just know they're there and they're safe
is a wonderful thing and and i think
you know that's something that we will
probably do
yeah i'm gonna follow her she's a doula
in the family so i'm just gonna say i'm
just gonna do this
you think of the pyramid mayday family
what does it look like is it is it a lot
of kids is it maybe just one kid
i want four kids on a big family i want
to be able to make sure that
the the gatherings at the dinner table
and the gatherings at holidays is full
of excitement and fun
if we just have like one child i feel
like it's not enough distraction like i
want a whole bunch of people in the
house
they don't all have to come from our
bodies though yeah
they don't all have to come from our
bodies and i don't think they should i
think
you know our plan was to each be able to
carry
and have a baby so that's two and then
if
we find ourselves i mean i've always
been open and felt very drawn to
adoption
so i love that um and we share that
in common you know wanting that really
kind of picture-esque family
dinner loud house things we didn't
really grow up with
yeah like i want to experience home
alone but like not
actually leave a child what else can we
be forgetting
kevin i love it i cannot wait for the
day when
we have the the pyramid may day
full-blown soccer team in the suv
um it's gonna be beautiful and i thank
you ladies for for sharing that
in the meantime i hope you're getting
ready to celebrate
what will be your one year anniversary
of marriage
how are you planning to celebrate we
actually cannot
tell you because there is a video on it
and we don't want to spoil it
please within the next weeks check out
the channel
i surprise miranda with her anniversary
present
and it's i kind of want to tell her but
i kind of don't know no no we shouldn't
tell
you just a little bit how do we tell her
like just a little bit though
is it a great gesture is it a is it a
thing
or was it an experience well it hasn't
happened yet
uh but you know what it is yeah yeah she
had to she had to
end up telling me it's because there's
paperwork involved it is an experience
it's it tackles some of
our favorite things meaning mental
health
um and mental health and mental health
you can say that we can say that
it tackles mental health and people
might think raven that's not romantic
but
you're not in my relationship so i don't
care about you listen i love this woman
i think she's absolutely fantastic and
like i tell her
in the video like i tell her in the
video just know
i'm not the romantic one to throw roses
and
you know baby puppies at her because
she'll be like i'm going to take care of
it i'd be like right let me just get you
a sweet potato
um so i'm going to make sure that she's
here
and raven with the unconventional
approach to celebrating the anniversary
miranda what do you have planned for
your lady
yeah what'd i get so i am a bit more
romantic
and i just i've
got raven something that we will keep
for the rest of our lives it's a very
sentimental beautiful gift and
then there are some little treats that
are going to be sprinkled within the day
one year into marriage what have you
learned about each other gosh we've
learned
a lot you know the evolution of our
relationship
when i think back on it is so wild like
thinking about
the raven i knew six years ago to the
raven i know today
so much growth so much change however
however there have been some really
consistent things
and one of them is raven is
so kind and so generous and so loving
and i think what has really happened for
me over the last year is my admiration
and respect for her has grown
raven are you tearing up no she's not i
mean if i
if i cried i'd be crying right now but i
don't cry i have a
you know hard heart um i think that our
relationship is um what i've learned
most about myself miranda and our
relationship
on the overall is that
i've been selfish my entire life
i have been such a selfish human being
because of the industry that i've been
in
and i've always put work first even
before friendship and everything else
and in my first year of marriage just
that
transfer over of loving someone more
than the industry
and putting that person first and that
person's needs first even before my own
is definitely a journey for myself as an
egotistical bee
yet someone who wants to see the person
that i live with
happier than anything ever well i wish
you both a very happy and healthy
first wedding anniversary and so many
more anniversaries to come
june is pride month it's such an
exciting time
i want to know what does pride mean to
you miranda
pride means to me being brave enough
being strong enough to live your truth
and celebrating that not just for the
month of june but every day
because our time here is limited and
[Music]
we should relish in it
that was a great answer and and yeah
raven i see you getting
uh a little emotional about it what does
it mean to you
to not only celebrate pride but to to be
an important part of this community
everything that she said mm-hmm on top
of the fact that i get to kiss a girl
every day and nobody can say anything
about it it makes me very happy and not
just a girl i mean her you
i know that pride is a beautiful
celebration
of coming together and something about
the lgbtqia
plus community i like to think it's an
open and accepting community so who
whoever you are you're welcome and i
wish there were more
places in the world that honored and
you know pushed out that messaging and
i think pride is a great celebration and
then remembering of
that motto or mission rather isn't she
great with that
like these great choices prolific
raven do you remember your first pride
my first
pride that i was comfortable enough
stepping into the mix-up
was actually in san francisco and
i was so nervous i was so nervous that
people would see me
i mean in my mind i just said well i can
celebrate it no matter what my sexuality
is even though obviously i was
you know all of it and i didn't i only
like um so the pride was going like this
and i was on a side street and i just
stuck my toe on the main street and like
powered back and watched the rest of it
from my apartment building
oh we'll talk about it later such a
journey and then
cut two you being like on a float waving
well
type two i'm going to be guest
hosting the pride for la on abc
this year and i'm like
for the second time right it's called a
journey